senti questa ciao sono di solito
registra l'italia è oggi non ha bisogno
della ruota delle pendenze delle torri
rete di testa e nuove torture che se
avete consigliato come su incantati
cattivissimi alcune erano terribili
sorpresa 10 st zo i nuovi drive monster
portion slow bis
messi non vedo l'ora di aprire questa di
oggi la chiusura non sono in queste
competizioni bellissima e le
bottigliette proprie tipo pozione quindi
vediamo chi sarà il fortunato a cui mi
capiteranno i famigerati distrutti to
dovremo archiviare ammortizzare prima a
votare cose vinco io se vince vitale in
posa altri 100 e alla sorprese che
beccheremo vediamo subito ghini si altro
carta palazzo
[Musica]
cazzo che ha detto posizione il museo
non è questa la frittata all'ora di
pranzo la voglia di braccio l'olio e
alla penitenza è che devi metterlo
scorso in faccia in che senso faccia è
di tipo tirare le sopracciglia il naso
la bocca di mi.to dove lo preferisci ok
di sicuro no perché infront e faccia i
capelli secondo zurnal tema sul naso poi
ci sono le sopracciglia
[Musica]
respirare e al trenino della maialina
quindi mi sono beccato lo preoccupi di
tester vive ten i commenti contati sta
bene dal limiterebbe il bravo evviva la
stessa potrai passo
prendete anzi spero che vi capiti quel
unicorno vediamo ogni giorno ma che
fortuna questo perché sono quattro sono
quattro personaggi siano brino triplano
finalmente vediamo un po come questo
nuovo claim 10 giu che bello un sacco di
sfumature dentro con uno viola e
rosanero neanche metallizzato e viene in
allegato con il magazine
quindi andiamo a vedere subito come
magra crimi allora in pratica e tema
fantasy infatti pozione e sono quattro
personaggi ali di fatah che viola bava
di troll che è un blu metallizzato
polvere di ricordo che questo che io che
è multicolor e soffio di drago che
quindi sono quattro contribuzioni da
collezionare
qui che si teneva colorare c'è anche la
fata il drago è l'unico che come lo
riconosce zucchero e poi c'è anche la
storia trova le 10 di fare bene
purtroppo fanno ma ora non vedo l'ora di
vedere come il nostro slime ok andiamo
ad aprirlo particolarità di questo slam
e che scende come un liquido ma si tocca
come un solido quindi immagino come una
sorta di gb ram e sommergibili pesante
liquido a questa fortunata da lodare il
bellissimo che siano un po tesi sembra
acqua rumori anno era qua c'è un blu
metallizzato poi abbiamo rosa e viola
allora lo slime è super gigi si
assomiglia a quello che avevo fatto io
tempo fa tipo lo slime water slime che
sembravo io adori tipiche slime e
vediamo un po che sony fa eco fa
professione a quote si è quindi ti paul
wauters lime
adoro il fatto che abbia questi colori
stupri è veramente il cycling sembra
water slime veramente bello quindi
questa è la mia polvere di un in corner
già collezionato 1
ho visto da un canale che si chiama di
letteratura di bambole che urtava questi
tipi di slime quindi questo slang potion
globi non stava per far giocare le lol
ed era bellissimo perché sembrava che la
loro fosse in una piscina praticamente e
quindi voglio provare anche allora in
pratica basta prendere il coperchio
della lol della bordella lol
puoi mettere lo slime dentro un ruolo è
un'immigrata eva crea tipo la piscina
delle lola anche perché a questo punto
non si attacca niente vedete non è
appiccicoso per niente quindi prendiamo
la nostra lol
ecco l'accordo e la portiamo in vergine
dentro e non si incolla quindi può
rimanere a galla così oppure la potete
immergere dentro c'è è fighissimo
proviamo a mettere anche lario di corno
di nome la piscina per lì non voi mondo
è che rimbalza immergiamo la lolla il
perché abbia la sua sauna personale il
gioco nessun altro slaibé sforzo
turbando
tutti
[Musica]
il viaggio lo stesso venga lavora
vediamo un po come ali di fatta guerra
che per coloro che all'interno si
schiaccia la pozione perche una caccia
che assilla il contenitore dato che
appartiene a questo sembra acqua che
beviamo e new york e bei colori e
sfumature bellissimo perché metallizzato
o 11 ma non siamo ancora pari perché tu
devi prendere una penitenza ma continua
giocata io vada io potrei prendere anche
se lo slime va bene adesso in poi prendi
sono pendenti la rai
a richiesta si poteva capitare fatto di
diverso almeno non chiudere la bocca
[Musica]
l'idea geniale dritta lady scocciarmi il
labbro e ringrazio perché resta
schiacciata da un po che in terra
sono stata zitta e comunque perché
proprio ridetto cocconato da maialino
[Musica]
scelgo io allora cosa si sono auto li
deciso perché ci abbiamo ancora il
soffio di drive mappa di troll e io
ancora non ho questo qui unicorno
allora io ho deciso di prendere sonno
milano perché hai copiato questo settore
voglio anch'io adesso lo facciamo uscire
piano piano formale meno metallizzato e
bene che viene sportive su questo cibo
con sei mio modo che il colore
bellissimo berna sforzi grieco
metallizzato forse no ho realizzato lo
stesso perché parli così una zona
bellissima
sempre ieri ma non è vero che c'erano
due bellissime creato o anni di fatah si
è soliti drago della missione il
controllore perché le voglio
condizionare anche mentre adesso mi
prenderò anche io poi allungabile non è
tanto che mi aiuto con i capelli ma
scusate abbiamo attaccato improntato
così normale all.re io ti avrei tirato
le sopracciglia noi userò bravo
[Musica]
a parlare non è certo tutta qualche
foglia in questo maledetto rossetto che
non è detto che questo non è affatto
divertente non è affatto diverso
divertendo scheletrone e non c'è nessun
divertimento anche della vita delle
dotazioni scrivete che foto di dati alla
10a finita la crisi il pulcino gira
viaggio
no allora in questo mini senza domandare
il ghiaccio tutto diversi iaio questo
viaggio è venuto più fritte da vicino
alla normale che mi piacerebbe i denti
per il mio nome non ce la faccio a
spezzarlo venite a dopo l'acqua e freddo
come mario mi affretto è un retto e si
noti che è quello alfredo alfredo oggi
alfredo rota civitate
come si sa montrone fermarlo ricerche è
così questo lo sforzo così rimane caldo
chris martin bellissimo che tutto nel
suo discorso in queste smorfie cavolata
mamma mia come ai clienti prendo io la
perché se tu lo schiacci con i denti
didietro nome scientifico di via
transiti dietro bay non posso variare
l'assetto addio ha superato la prova
[Musica]
grande artista come true carità tutti
sostituiti tutti allora facciamo queste
guardi un po più rock
non sono per niente felice di nato come
aspetto cosa sopracciglia dobbiamo
scoprirle un pochino prodotto questo
vuoto non si toglie rimane per sempre
che ben ma che i marchi ritirato tumulti
faccia il prezzo è anche anche soffio i
dragoes i dragoes e quindi mancava
eccolo qua il mio mondo e poi son pausa
di krol
vediamo un po come questo bellissimo
blue metallic
[Musica]
ecco la posizione
nessuna mozione di rete e come dicevamo
noi a sud è anche questo che figata
sembrato però liquido però non lo è
anche questo super g glia abbiamo unito
due monster pot online.it è ancora più
gravi del fighissimo numero bellissimi
valore per metallizzati e appunto ci si
può giocare con elogi molletta che vuol
dire che andremo a spendere in vestiti e
andiamo attendere dopo la tua forza la
realtà
io non mi sto divertendo in questa
gialla dove andiamo anche tre bollette
dalle fermate locandina no mini con i
money no allora che svegli vicini così
fernando 14 parola se prima il trucco
non riesce a resistere no bisogna per
forza che le mettono
dopo le due belle dei media percorsa la
mettiamo sul dato respiro con la bocca
un anno perché tocca un massimo di nove
semi capisco perché fare la colletta
scappa torna scapola bolletta
mamma mia
[Musica]
ora è vista questore dottor andatevi mai
piano e non mi vuoi cercare con il
pennello nel particolare sta godendo
ormai ma io ti ho fi truccata come
funziona il meccanismo bastano tutti
scuri questioni metterti quelli di
doppiatori scuri più divertiamo un po di
colore tosto derivare piano piano ma
attento ma magari l'ombretto anche io
non ho dormito qualche prova che sono
colorando senza un senso logico dopo il
video del silenzio dopo il video di ieri
che ho colorato tutti mi hanno detto che
sono stato chiuso la brava collare
allora coloriamo la faccia della mente
ma tutto coroniamo perde così vi indico
di tutto quello che hai fatto vivo
ma non adesso questo trova niente
[Musica]
tutti hanno detto che solo provo a
colorare e quindi diventa scusa per fare
tutta la barba roba sta così bene
vogliamo poi venderli a un po di
rossetto mia io armato di un uomo adesso
è una bolletta di slay monster pot che
potete trovare in edicola a 2 euro e 99
in delegato con la grande titolare
perché mai avrei produttivo per me e per
tutti di sapere qual è il vostro
preferito tra ali di fatah a polvere di
unicorno a di troll e sofia di drago
qual è il vostro personaggio preferito
scrivetelo nei commenti belli mi è super
rosa
che bello
ho quindi ma che si sa per tutte le
commette scriveteci anche altre
penitenze facciamo nel box da socrate
quindi tendo a fare già nessuno avrei
detto che hanno sempre tutto il pari nel
prossimo video della ruota delle
penitenze delle torture ci siamo ridotti
veramente male questa volta e per
fortuna non ci sono capitati metti il
numero civico garanzini piccantissimi
momo della prossima volta ci capiterà
lasciarli on line
chicca nessuna di queste quattro casse
cinema per vedere i nostri altri video e
buona visione
ciao